[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and I'm here to bring you Premium
Format oh my gosh
Apocalypse Now um how can I say this
that movie that we saw with apocalypse
and x-men
by Fox that was probably one of my worse
excellent movies for the simple fact
that apocalypse isn't this scrawny dude
when he burst on the scene he wasn't
that x-men per se villain you know I'm
getting ahead of myself again guys do me
a favor
like follow and subscribe hit that
notification button so next time Kos
pops up you can get all that Kos news hi
so this guy here we're going to go into
the universe to the film universe
because it's not too MCU he's gonna be
an MCU and they're gonna do him justice
unlike that x-men movie that didn't do
him justice so let's be honest who is
apocalypse and what is his powers okay
apocalypse debuted in x-factor the
original x-factor books now the x-factor
is made up of um the original x-men
Cyclops
the angel the Beast Iceman and Jean Grey
as you know Marvel Girl whatever so all
right when he debuted over there you
know and caused some havoc over there
because I don't think they had a villain
for them you know they were tired of
using like magneto
and x-men villain so they had to come up
with a villain apparently he is the
oldest living mutant so people will
probably define him as the one right and
a lot of books was written like in the
Bible the Quran or the Torah or other
books about his exploits so they try to
say that this dude is the guy in every
you know like stage that they're talking
about he is you know
those heroes or villains or whatever in
the books so what do we know about
apocalypse that we can give you without
getting it all convoluted because they
came in and they read Kondos and they
changed this and they did a whole bunch
of stuff I'm gonna give you my initial
interpretation of the character and then
you know if I get another statue I can
give you another interpretation of the
character when he first came out he
brought a bunch of hell with him but
what he did was he rolled with his Four
Horsemen of apocalypse now they lead
live by the credo only the strong
survive so what they would do is bring
in times of tribulation the four
horsemen show up led by Apocalypse
himself he is the apocalypse bringing
the four horsemen death pestilence
notice that plague and famine right and
all the horsemen will have those powers
so but what he does is he gives these
guys these power he's enhancing them his
power himself is believed psionic little
telekinesis matter manipulation and
photon blast out of the cannon that he
can you know turn his arm into like he
can grow in size and and he's immensely
strong almost invulnerable all of this
is brought across because of the he
found celestial one of the ancient
beings and he merged with them and took
their technology his armor is basically
made of celestial stuff so that's why
he's he can live forever he throws to
suffer like a Odin type of sleep and he
recharges his batteries his energies to
get his strength back from the earth and
you know from the Fallen celestial now
let's get into why I got this statute
this statute was a long journey to me is
actually a mistake statute this is not
even a statue that I have won a per say
myself found myself gambling on eBay and
this is how you can gamble on eBay you
pick a statue that you don't really want
at a price that you say I'm not gonna
live what if I get it so I put a price
in right did I know that I was gonna win
the statute Hales to the note so I'm
going about my day get alert you won I
won the hell are you talking about I won
I won what
well must've behind put in a bid and I
didn't think that it was gonna win
because I saw all this other statues
gone for seven hundred eight hundred
dollars right so I'll put in a bid for
three hundred dollars right
yeah I won that's how I got the statute
so the statue comes in the mill did not
know that it was just big all right come
to the box he's the same size or if not
a little bit big run the same size of my
gladiator hope that one day I might do
he came showed up got the Box open now
he has a couple of flaws on him all
right but it wasn't no not too big you
know nothing you know gigantic but after
what looking at the statue after opened
it over he's here get the art box not
the shipping box got the statue so you
know we automatically in with it right
we're only live now now we live now it's
the thing all right now I gotta find a
space for this dude so the base the base
he's on is actually the celestial type
of base from the ship that he's in right
and the boots is just like in the comic
books
looks like metallic heavy boots his uh
the paint application on him is very
impeccable I'm not gonna lie because in
some of the solid parts the blue parts
you can see a metallic type of paint
that you see like a little sparklies
inside of the paint which is a really
nice touch I'm not gonna lies it's a
very nice touch the the parts that are
supposed to be great
are grade the parts that are supposed to
be blue are blue his face is probably
the standout featured to me because his
face comes across of like the first face
that they did on the x-factor comic book
and I was like you know what it's not a
bad statue now oh I don't have the
exclusive one the exclusive one instead
of that big cannon he's able to switch
it to like chainsaw because he can
matter manipulate his body into like
different things like a ball and chain
and stuff like that um
those cables that go around him is made
out of plastic that bendable they're
flexible they're going like little pegs
inside the back of him and on the sides
and he's robust the muscular structure
of the character is exactly like the
books so not like the movie where boy oh
don't get me started anyway it's a very
good statue it's one of the biggest ones
the sideshow put out early on you know
so he can compete with the likes of I
guess they got they juggernaut coming
now and you know the Hulk that I do have
and a couple of Hawks that are coming so
he's a very robust statute in your
collection if you actually want to
produce a villain and you definitely
have to extract their characters or the
x-men characters this is a great
addition to your mutant lineup like he's
going to be one of the stars inside my
mutant room so it's a it's definitely a
good pickup if you can get them all
right I don't think you get them at that
price but what can I say well here we go
we're at the end of a part of the video
and you're gonna stick around for to
watch the videos and the pictures of the
character I'm gonna tell you like follow
subscribe also go to loads of gaming net
we can get all the latest information on
the opinion pieces hardcore reviews from
Lord addict the last word from Lord
Cognito and the bond tests combat talk
with the king that's myself where I go
over boxing and you know some MMA here
in there don't know too much about MMA
but I definitely know my boxing and you
know we have a couple of good fights and
stuff like that coming up so that's a
good thing for you you know : check out
we have overwatch information by Gondo
condo condos um
and it's a very good site I'm not saying
it because our site but I'm just saying
it because it's definitely a
read a lot of information and it's very
easy to navigate
you know shout out too high for putting
that Nightwatch mold on oh we needed
that baby all right so uh stick around
watch the video and see you next week
when I give you someone who can possibly
do some incredible stuff next week guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]